- And onto another wonder woman.
Last month I had Kaley Cuoco here
to talk about her HBO Max
show, the "Flight Attendant".
We got to chatting so much
that I didn't want our
conversation to end, I love her.
That means we couldn't fit
everything in that past show.
So we're gonna show
you the rest of it now.
Check out this Kaley extra.
I have to ask you this, so
have you ever, cause I have,
have you ever had a night
that you can't recall?
Like, 'cause you said you wake
up in the "Flight Attendant"
and you're there and there's a dead person
and you don't remember what happened,
have you ever had that night?
- Yes.
- You have?
- One time.
- Now did yours involve alcohol?
- Yes.
That's when Kaley learned
that we don't drink sake anymore, so.
- Third person.
- That's a true story.
Yeah, I speak in third
person about that night
'cause that was, it was
actually with my husband.
We were not married at
the time we were dating.
- [Kelly] Oh, and he's still married you?
- He still married me,
this is why he is a keeper.
Yes, we had a crazy night
and we went and got the sushi
and it was the sake and
it was all this sake.
And I woke up the next
morning, I'm not kidding,
and this was at a horse show,
see, you know, the horse show world.
In the summer, all day.
- Oh, you're so hot.
- Riding head to toe, just
sweaty, riding horses all day.
I woke up in my full riding outfit
with my tall boots on, hat, swear to God,
hair still in a not from under my helmet,
laying on the couch like this.
And I woke up, and I was like.
- Well, you know what didn't happen.
- Yeah, yeah, no, I was
fully clothed, fully clothed.
- [Kelly] Sorry, Carl.
- No one enjoyed that night.
And I go, "What happened?"
And he's like, "Sake happened."
- Oh my God.
- And I said, I can't
drink that ever again.
- I've never had sake.
- I never drink it again by the way.
- I will take your warning.
- It really got me, it got me.
- Mine, wasn't alcohol,
mine was not cool at all.
Mine was, I was at like CVS
getting like fulfilling,
filling some prescription
'cause I'd had dental
work on the day before.
And I look in my bag and I
have these jewelry boxes.
And I'm like, "The hell."
Like I have literally
five to six big boxes
of jewelry in my bag.
And I'm like, "Did I
like rob someone house?"
- Did you steal somewhere.
- I was like, "What's happening?"
And I literally, I call my assistant.
I'm like, at CVS, like filling this thing.
And I'm like, "What?"
I was like, "Dude, do
you know whose jewelry
I have in my bag?"
And then my assistant proceeds to go,
"Well, we went shopping."
And I was like, "What?"
- You just bought.
- And she was like,
"What do you mean, what?
We weren't shopping, like
after rehearsal with the band,
then we went shopping and
then we went to dinner."
I had a full night-
- [Kaley] You don't remember.
- Completely with eyes open walking around
that I don't remember.
- No.
And my band's laughing
because I had rehearsal
with them for my album,
Meaning of Life.
And apparently, what did I say?
- [Man] That aint my song.
- That aint my fault.
- I was literally at
rehearsal, sitting in a chair,
apparently like this with
sunglasses and they're playing,
and I go, and with a mic was
like, "That ain't my song."
- Oh my God.
- Like I was so high form the dentist.
- The dentist, so you don't
remember buying the jewelry
or the dinner or anything?
- I, no, I went to my friend's house.
She was like, "This is my house."
Don't remember seeing the house.
Sometimes, apparently
you're on something that-
- [Kaley] You're just like, woo, sure
- What did the dentist
gives me is my question.
- Wow, and where can we get it now?
- And where can we.
- Is the real question
- Well, I wanna remember it.
And I had, I bought some
good jewelry, but yeah.
- Well, that's good, you
know that is the thing,
it's like a party, you know, whatever
that obviously wasn't a party for you.
But I wanna remember the night,
like I don't wanna get to that point
where I don't even enjoy.
- Yeah, I didn't remember one thing.
All of that was from what people told me.
- Yeah, that is unbelievable.
- Except for me being at the pharmacy
and the drive thing going,
"What is all these jewelry?"
- The amount of jewelry,
I love that you thought
that you robbed someone.
- I literally was like, "Did
I take someone's jewelry?"
I was like, there's like
so many boxes of jewelry,
I surely didn't just go
and buy all these, I did.
In order to not forget making
it, you got tattoos, right?
- Yes, so me and my co-star,
Zosia, we got little tattoo.
- [Kelly] What a cool name.
- Like the coolest name of all time.
- Yeah.
- I know.
We actually got tattoos,
you probably can't see it, it's very small
but it's a little paper airplane
to kind of a little-
- "Flight Attendant."
- Yes, the "Flight Attendant."
- You're cute.
- Me and, oh, there it is, on there.
Actually wardrobe girls, we
became very close with the girls
on the show and we all went and got one
and it was a really sweet experience.
- [Kelly] That's awesome,
do you have any other ones?
- I have a handful, but-
- I have so many.
- Right, do you regret any
of the ones that you got?
- I don't, and if I, if I
ever have ones that I'm like,
then I changed them into something else.
- Oh, that's good.
- Yes.
- I've actually,
I've had to do that a
couple of times, yeah.
- [Kelly] Was it a name?
- It was a, it was a, yes, pretty much.
I just, here's the thing I-
- I always tell people don't get names.
- I know, and trust me, I'm so dumb.
- [Kelly] You just don't know.
- Like why, why, why?
- Yeah, turn it into
something else, cover it up.
- Turn it into something else.
I also have a, I got when I
was, I think I was probably 17.
I probably wasn't even allowed to get one.
- You were 20 with your tramp
stamp, you have a tramp stump?
- I have a tramp stamp, but here is,
yes, do you have a tramp stamp?
- I don't.
- God, you put them in
good spots, I'm so jealous.
I, although I'm hearing something,
I'm hearing that the tramp stamp
and everything from like
early 2000s is coming back.
- [Kelly] Oh it's circling.
- This is what I'm thinking.
- Is this what you tell yourself or-
- Yes, about anything that I've,
any mistake I go, "It's coming
back, it's coming back.".
- I have, literally, almost
all of my girlfriends
from Texas have it, and I
don't know why, just never.
- I thought it was so cool.
Gotta get that tramp stump.
- I think because I
have such a large behind
I was like, "I don't really want to like,"
like even in my thin moments,
like it's really there.
And I just didn't think
attracting attention was the best.
- I think what's funny
too is during that time
it was when the low jeans were so in.
Like the remember, like the-
- Oh see, I have one right here,
all the the girls did that, yeah.
But I'm going to be honest with you
Texas is 3D now, so, yeah.
- [Kaley] 3D.
- Yeah, 'cause I have had two children
and Texas is now it's
three dimensional, yeah
It's got some weird shading,
yeah it's different.
- [Kaley] That is hilarious.
- What's the story, why did
you get the tramp stump,
what's your tramp stamp?
- 'Cause I thought it was,
it was like a dumb symbol
and I want, you know, I used
to wear the really low jeans.
- [Kelly] So it'd peak
out, that's kinda cute.
- Yeah, but now my jeans
couldn't get any higher.
They come up here now.
- Yeah, 'cause now-
- Now we want the high waist.
- Yes.
- So now it's like way down there.
- Yeah.
- I don't mind I love tattoos.
I have a few.
- Me too.
- I just wish I had thought about
what I was putting on there.
I think when you're
younger, you want it so bad.
or don't really think
the steps through, right?
So I just wish I got
something different but.
- I think why I don't regret them
I was in that chapter and
that moment in your life,
you like this was cool,
this was what I wanted.
And that's kind of it, like I don't ever-
- [Kaley] Now It's coming back around.
- Yeah, tell everyone.
- It's coming back, okay.
The tramp stump is
coming back, I've heard.
- Seriously, I love her,
remember to check Kaley out
in the "Flight Attendant"
streaming now on HBO Max.